thank you for calling this was two-tone
I'm happier I just picked up my 92
accord from your life and it is a huge
turn in the back seat and there's what
there's one back seat in the back seat
of my car
BAM I assure you our guys did not take a
dump in your car if you want to bring
that car back and we'll take a look at
it yo you want to take a look at it
my car is fine it's that big turd in the
backseat okay what would you like me to
do actually okay how about I go to your
house and pinch a loaf on your couch how
about that ma'am what would you like me
to do to fix the situation I want
somebody come over here get this turn
out my backseat I can bring the car here
and will you take a look at it oh yeah
bring it back there you know what I'm
gonna do I'm gonna take a dump in every
last call you got there I'm going P o yo
counter imma do it all you how it feels
okay know what you sound like a big
burly man it probably came out joyous oh
yeah I don't make it a habit of going
out and taking a dump in the car where
do you weigh about 400 pounds y'all turn
yes that came up from a 400-pound
gorilla I'm driving this car right to my
lawyer's office and I'm gonna let the
whole world see you're gonna be on the
news this evening buddy I'm gonna get
seven oh my side what you gonna be on
the news and he describes as I mean
what's it look like you know what it is
it came out your ass what kind of ask me
what color I tell you what it smells
ungodly that's what it smells like smell
it smells like you sold your ass to the
devil I got a damn 2x4 in my back seat
you know I think I think there's some
racial - that's what
little kids I'll run away from it
it's all fine is funny your private
jacket all for the wheels to take this
is a fresh dough okay what you need to
do is you need to bring that turn back
and we'll match it up we have a lineup
we'll match it up with the UH with the
other turds that we have well what you
need to do is learn how to use a toilet
I'm saying I can bring the third back to
me know I'm starting to like it I'm
gonna keep it in the back well keep it
because it's a nice book you know what
is a nice conversation piece okay okay
[Music]